[Music]
three two one action
welcome to off-the-record where we talk
about whatever we want
[Applause]
that's right welcome to twenty episodes
of me figuring out how to use a Mac
Macintosh but when it's a computer is
going up Mac yeah if you're like eighty
you called it a Maggie Tosh you guys
ever have had one rich people it's a Mac
it's a MacBook MacBook yeah it's a
MacBook Macintosh book PC picture the
Apple logo the rainbow has yes oh my god
and I forgot about that until you
[ __ ] gave me that memory back in my
last time that I've used a Macintosh why
what's what's better like about the PC
yeah I mean cuz I'm silence right now
okay it's cuz I'm a gamer you know it's
personal preference if you're like an
artist and you like do like video
editing and all that stuff then great
get a Macintosh oh you know what it is I
know I know that PC is better period
there's no competition it's right jobs
the Mac is just easier to use for idiots
yeah yeah I'm an idiot
so it's considering I have to figure
this out like I was like if how do I
click on this it's so stupid easy like
it's it's super easy everything
connection if you want to customize
things I think the PC is the way to go
mmm I play gay I play a lot of like
video games yeah so like I have to like
you know say like the memory in like
yeah this is like you can save a video
on this no people
would you guess it is what would you get
like this for save also okay and here's
my here's my biggest problem with it
it's too goddamn expensive like it
really is like I've gone through these
phases that's true I would like a
Macintosh because stall Percival and
just push this down see I would like a
mic I want to get one because I was like
oh this is like the expensive it's like
a status thing and I googled it and I
was like I no longer wish to have what
it's like six how come you chose 7
iPhone over and Android that your face
real goes buzzing - this is like both
Bozeman this is a real action and like I
think that iPhone users can be honest
with themselves because we all know the
one reason why we all have iPhones whoo
that's right when somebody text you with
a green text like you get somebody's
number and they hit you with that green
text you're like oh hey this is me or
when you're in a group chat and there's
one person with an Android and they
screw it up for everything I mean you
can't gave it David he's changing back
he's changing back davis change you back
you realize he [ __ ] up again because
you he went back to iphone after night
Android and then now he's gonna go and
he went back to Android now he's gonna
go back again cuz he says also with like
media you know what I want to send
pictures or videos to do especially with
this podcast really hard to send videos
to text yeah and also David otherwise he
would have to text it and he won't even
give me his number
David has explicitly told me like I will
not give you my number I'm going to do
the podcast I'm like oh hey David here's
my number he was like just just DME wait
why don't you notice though that texting
someone with the Android it feels like
it's slower yes because they all type
slow
nope contest at ICON about smoke you got
airplane mode yeah that swipe ship else
mom where it is it's cuz I use it on my
computer so I'd like to I use my [ __ ]
eye chats right oh so then if you're
using Wi-Fi it doesn't connect it's not
the same if I can take forever is that
mind blowing to you that your phone's
not connected to your laptop yes you
feel left out I thought about that and I
understand that there are some people
that they chat online with their laptop
chat through this with your laptop like
a chat yeah never that tells me you guys
don't work if you don't know what like
that Safari on your phone and then you
pull up your laptop
it'll ynx it so you can open up that
page your Safari I don't give a [ __ ] I
used to be super PC but then I got lazy
cuz every time you got to learn you got
to customize things and then you just
stopped caring after a while is the best
though
I've always been on PC but then also you
know how like sometimes you want to like
learn new stuff like I don't even know
how to use a Macintosh I just don't like
I don't like the dumb you know how to
use it because it's so stupid easy it
really is made for idiots
well I grew up on an IBM compatible and
that's the best original toast
that's an old [ __ ] the original term is
to be Macintosh and IBM compatible
because the OS is IBM but no one has
actual I be M you're old
I don't know how does a company have
like the same exact products but they
get us they give us like I can't explain
it like everything's kind of got a
different name like you said like IBM
they both gonna hate it then iPad then
I've had it's all part of Macintosh and
it's not called iWatch why isn't it
called
i watch yeah I do either Apple TV yeah
why the [ __ ] maybe it sounds stupid
rebranding it must have been a meeting
yet it was like is it gonna be i watch
Apple one when they make a car you think
is gonna be a car I want them to make
remake Google glass I think that came
out like 10 years ago that [ __ ] was nerd
[ __ ] what happened to that I know there
was commercials for names like this is
the future they were just like this with
the [ __ ] thing and they just stupid
you know you know I like I think PC [ __ ]
is better but then it doesn't get much
popularity or whatever is the designers
what's that swag down that's what I'm
saying
Nicki dude sorry you're right I have a
PC laptop over there just like nice I
think more people would rather have the
easy route and have less options yeah
it's what preset I want to think less
yeah it's definitely over a lot of too
many choices
just give me a give me a menu alright I
just get a steak you know you don't have
to go into details right now kills it
because they only have three options in
and out of bones in and out of phones
Hawk you look a good talker what do you
do
thank you I'm a professional talker it's
from Australia Bart was like God his
Australian accent is like off and I was
right mmm that's funny because uh yeah
there's this tiny island in Australia
called England he doesn't sound
Australian I know but what's so weird is
like what I don't know where I got this
notion are you from Australia and so for
like the last I don't know ten years or
seven years I've known you or not known
I've known of you
yeah it's you've always been Australian
because you're Australian in my mind I
automatically assumed you're Vietnamese
Vietnamese guy have a Japanese name
that's British did you think you were
one of those guys that they're like
they're like they try to be Japanese but
they're not Japanese y'all they do that
like yeah we meet nummies adopted I
don't know I find out next year that I'm
actually getting names and you do a 23
of me I haven't yet I haven't yet
because I think my results gonna be
really boring mine's pretty boring
Japanese people I feel like they're
either Japanese or just a tiny bit
Chinese or something it's not like oh I
got like 3% Italian and like it's not
that interesting I was I was 98%
Japanese and I checked again last month
no I'm 99% I was 1% Korean and then it
went away because you know the more data
it gets the more specific the better
yeah the pool is so I'm ninety-nine
point you can't really go back and like
see your whole lineage where my [ __ ]
like people just got great it goes like
this or like can it show you like if you
have like a sibling or something that's
a society tells you your relatives like
your percentage of relatives I had a out
of time this was like a couple years ago
so like my dad is like I'm part native
and obviously like so it comes from my
dad so he's like obviously more native
and like you have to be like in 1/8 to
qualify to be tribally registered and so
because like my dad's really close to
the tribe and everything when I came to
visit they were just like yeah here's
your card like no tests everything's
fine oh cool what tribe are you from
Wampanoag yeah but no so my dad he did
one of those 23andme tests and he called
me he was like listen I can't tell
anyone else and I'm like what's going on
dude he's like we're not as native as I
thought
to be fair he thought he was like 75%
and like I still like barely make the
mark I probably shouldn't but no I don't
know it's any of the whomps out there
I'm sorry you guys seen it oh yeah yeah
it was like he was like listen we're not
he was like that but not wedding and
he's like I gotta send you something
yeah well I mean but it was so funny
because like there was like some weird
section we were like 10% Pacific
Islander and I was like what yeah it was
like 10% but here so that means I'm only
like like a little bit wait how does
that thing work good but where do they
get the data and like what if this [ __ ]
in a company says they look at and
they're like oh you're Japanese no it's
like they give you little vials and you
spit in it like that's all you do are
you asking about how they figure out
through DNA what ethnicity closely on it
it kind of is like a cornered and it's
like if you zoom in for us there's a
Japanese guy what glass is doing karate
black guy with a harmonica next to a
train close to Oxford so I'm act like I
know but where's Locke sir it's now like
from London from London
yeah it's like it's just a I would like
let me ask you this are there Japanese
people there so where I grew up there's
like none like me and my sister we were
the only are you nice eh uh no how you
can what do you say cuz in America we
say nice say for the firstborn in
America right first generation is the
first people to migrate here yeah well
mine's a little confusing cuz I was born
in Japan right now I moved to those
three like our whole family but then we
moved back to Japan
12 you're still you say then well it's
20 I came here by myself
so yeah I'm Japan from Japan and one
that yeah biggest reason was I was
afraid that I was gonna forget speak
English because you know in Japan
yeah like when you're surrounded by
everyone as Japanese you know your
school you don't we just like to come
here instead of back could you pass
sucks girl no there was an option to do
that but I just thought with this like a
study abroad thing England wouldn't
really be going abroad it's just like
going back you know so I want it to new
culture yeah I want to go see somewhere
that I didn't really know my friends
there so for some reason I think you're
gonna speak Japanese with an English
accent
I used to shop at the graph yeah it had
Delian mmm maybe now that way what what
do you want me to say I said I said
speak a little bit for me and then he
says what do you want me to say let's go
let's go to the pool together that booty
no cuz i yeah I hate it that's what
always makes me think like you if all of
us well you know there's Japanese
Brazilians or whatever right and then
like they speak Portuguese and all that
stuff but when we get together we speak
Japanese it doesn't sound like like like
we're you know we're speaking the accent
or something I do a little bit but I
think yeah cuz I moved back when I was
12 yeah and inside of me is just all
English you know cuz I there's no one's
Japanese and yeah and then I couldn't
really relate to the Japanese people
back in Japan you went to school up
there and when I was thinking everyone
was English so I was just a hundred
things yeah I did so when were in
England it was the rule was inside the
home was Japanese outside was English
don't mix it kind of thing what about if
you're talking to her on through a
window but you're outside like real fast
you think what if you're outside of a
window I sort of think your rules like I
thought so I think about lupo we have
three stages of Jeff you're born there
but then you're you're basically like
kind of even you know your English yeah
much culturally yeah yeah yeah and then
I was born here but my parents were born
in Japan okay and then this guy over
here is like my parents and my
grandparents were born here so is your
grandpa or grandparents came here what
my grandparents my grandparents were
born here but he was born here and then
he moved back and they they sent him
back to Japan no it's good yeah weird
family life so they sent him back to
live with his um with his family over
there I hope I'm sure he survived but
they do yeah that's crazy yeah cool it
was really stressful like figuring
everything out the first time but
there's a lot of cool stuff and like it
was very different it's like a Galapagus
it's like it's crazy how this day and
age is so that mean it's very
disconnected older it's something it's
very collaborative
like they sell CDs like musicians yeah
they flip bones man there's a lot of CDs
like what do you even play that on yeah
it's weird cuz they're technologically
advanced in a lot of different ways but
they still use CDs and like flip bones
and it's interesting I think cuz it's a
pretty wealthy country so if there's a
system that runs within itself yeah it
does really well like it doesn't have to
do well anywhere else and they do just
do what they want to do that I spoke or
do you think your ever return to go live
there again I don't think I can I wanted
to right up to a couple years ago when I
was like it I was just thinking yeah I'm
out man want to but people don't know
man like I think people fantasize about
Japan but it sucks to be Japanese living
in Japan it's
very different to being Japanese in
Japan especially if you're a foreigner
Japanese oh wait why well okay so you
guys get the foreigner card yeah which
which is like if you don't do anything
if you don't do if you do things that
violate the culture they're just a
stupid foreigner it's okay
cute little foreigner yeah but then for
us we were expected to know but we don't
get the four in our car because we're
Japanese so what happens then they know
they don't be we're just kind of [ __ ]
shun you they like yeah yeah they just
look like we just seem stupid because we
don't understand certain things and then
it's difficult to have close friends
that you can relate to because just
culturally we're so different and in
their very they're very one mind yeah
that's what I hate [ __ ] like when I had
an English accent with my Japanese I
hated it like I want it to be like
everyone else also I'm gonna study it
and speak Japanese better than you guys
and speak English better you guys you
know so it's like like like Hawk said
it's a it's a it's it's its own culture
right so it's how do you compare to
America right here we're so diverse
we're so different
we value individualism all that stuff so
imagine everything opposite is what's
cool over there
so individualism is not cool it's all
about collectivism so everybody tries to
be like each other you follow each other
it's very different but that's how you
have order and cleanliness and all sorts
of everything's like the things that you
can appreciate about the culture is also
what makes it kind of suck that's why
Hajduk who's interesting because they're
the Venice Beach or they're the artsy
weird but think about it how are tjuku
is Haruka Japan the rest of Japan is the
same it's just one little place where in
America you have Austin Texas keep it
weird you have keep it keep it smoggy
but but
city every city you have a weird kind of
thing right you don't have that over
there it's just how did you have that
little area in Tokyo yeah it's like the
side effects of this order you have 95%
of this order but because of that you
have a 5% of really crazy weird yeah
that's what I feel like they have those
like really weird fish and lay all that
because it's so suppressed you know oh
it's like suppressed like you have to be
like normal and conform to everything
but it's like when you're in the bedroom
it's like yeah that makes a lot of sense
cuz like it gets like what's the
explanation here then what do you mean
yeah I think it's the hard core
yeah religion I think whenever it's this
there's gonna be a balance of the
opposite you know that's true yeah where
are your [ __ ] 20 questions you kept
bugging about all these questions that
you answer all of them oh yeah cuz I
just I just realize you're not
Vietnamese from English fine you know
cos now even Japanese people don't
recognize that I'm Japanese really what
yeah because I find that your idea yeah
well I think naturally I'm already
pretty tan for a Japanese guy and this
hair and I think I think it's just like
the mannerism or the posture you know
it's very different to like a Japanese
person that that's true if you were bald
and in you're wearing that high school
uniform you look Japanese I don't even
like really like how you would act like
just little body language there's so
much more than relaxed this this is this
is being a good Japanese boy yeah and
it's just if I if I'm like this they're
like oh this was Chinese
I'm telling you guru there's so many
[ __ ] rules to be Japanese that people
don't understand it [ __ ] suck
I have no Japanese pride man it's all
about being [ __ ] Japanese American
bro y'all had like this unspoken code
when you were talking about earlier and
y'all about to just cut it off and not
explain why I was so hard I thought
y'all gonna be like oh he didn't shut
the door Killa hammer Hey
it was like that let me tell you how
[ __ ] up it was so now it's more loose
than it was before but in the past so
like if you shamed if you were if you're
if you destroyed the family name and
you're of the warrior class you have to
kill yourself
right that's what separate yeah so so
it's like oh I would be pissed I'll be
pissed if I did something small no like
you gotta [ __ ] stab yourself you're
dead now and you know someone has to
stand there next to you to chop your
head off because just yeah it takes time
to die just with that but you have to
actually do it yourself first and then
they'll do it they won't just chop your
head off and then the guy that you
choose to chop your head off is probably
your best friend or someone that is very
close to you the same so it sucks for
both people because the guy that's got
to chop your head off he wants to do a
clean ass job so you want someone that
you care about to do it so they'll do it
good that's honorable versus someone
that you hate they're probably gonna
make you suffer I always thought that
was tight as we did wait do I say do I
say time man said cut I was gonna tell
you like if you want to plug that all
right time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]